this morning police are still trying to
understand what led a doctor of medicine
to shoot up a New York City Hospital the
shooting left one doctor dead and six
other people wounded the gunman who died
during the rampage was forced to resign
from the hospital two years ago Roxana
Saberi is outside Bronx Lebanon hospital
with the latest Roxana good morning good
morning former colleagues described dr.
Henry bellow as very aggressive and
threatening police say the 45 year old
entered this hospital concealing an
assault rifle under a lab coat and made
his way up to the 16th floor
[Music]
the first 9-1-1 call came just before 3
p.m. after an active shooter penetrated
the upper floors of the Bronx Lebanon
hospital according to numerous reports
Bello had resigned from the hospital in
2015 after just six months to avoid
charges of sexual harassment he said he
was going to do this I didn't hear him
say but talking amongst us he said it
and he did it as first responders
entered the building employees were
instructed to hunker down and wait for
help
they put everybody in the one room I was
in their room and everybody laid down on
the floor my heart starts beeping and I
pray I call my pastor to pray for us
Gonzalo Carozza was on the twelfth floor
I saw blood on the floor I saw a doctor
with blood on his hands EMT Robert
Maldonado and his partner had just
arrived with the patient when they were
called up to the ninth floor to help a
victim I immediately put pressure on the
exit and the entrance wound my partner
assisted me the police department helped
us lift him and carry him all the way
down to the emergency room the gunman
was found on the 17th floor dead of an
apparent self-inflicted gunshot wound an
ar-15 assault rifle was nearby
dr. bellow had been arrested in the past
for harassing women the New York Daily
News is reporting that just hours before
the shooting he emailed the paper
claiming a female doctor at this
hospital for his termination Alex
Roxana Saberi thanks